SO MUCH MORE.
AND OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ALL RIGHT, TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ON A
COMPLETE TEAR BY CONTINUING
TO KEEP HIS PROMISES AND
ENACT THE AGENDA THAT YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, VOTED
FOR IN NOVEMBER 2016.
NOW, THE DHS SECRETARY
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN MADE A
MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT EARLIER
TODAY ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S PLAN TO SECURE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS
DIRECTED THE NATIONAL GUARD
PERSONNEL BE DEPLOYED TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AS
YOU KNOW HAS LONG SUPPORTED
THE EFFORTS OF DHS TO
PROTECT OUR NATION'S
BORDERS.
THIS INCLUDES ONGOING
COUNTER NARCOTIC MISSIONS,
INFRASTRUCTURE CONSTRUCTION,
PERSISTENT SURVEILLANCE
OPERATIONAL TRAINING AND
AERIAL ALLEY SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT WESTERN
HEMISPHERE.
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AND I THANK THEM
FOR THEIR SUPPORT.
WHILE PLANS ARE BEING
FINALIZED, IT'S OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THE
NATIONAL GUARD WILL DEPLOY
PERSONNEL IN SUPPORT OF
CPP'S BORDER SECURITY
MISSION.
>> Sean: TONIGHT WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS SIGNED THE PROCLAMATION
TO SEND THE NATIONAL GUARD
TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
NOW THE PRESIDENT, HE
DESERVES A LOT OF CREDIT
BECAUSE IF CONGRESS ARE NOT
GOING TO LIFT A FINANCING
TORE SOLVE THE PROBLEM, THEN
HE IS GOING TO TAKE THE
STEPS AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
AND DO IT ON HIS OWN, WHICH
HE NOW HAS.
NOW, BEFORE THE LIBERAL
MEDIA ALL YOU LEFTISTS OUT
THERE START LOSING YOUR
COLLECTIVE MINDS OVER THE
NATIONAL GUARD BEING
DEPLOYED AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, WE WILL EDUCATE
YOU.
THERE IS ALREADY PRECEDENCE
FOR AWFUL THIS WHILE GEORGE
W. BUSH AND BARACK OBAMA
THEY ACTUALLY DID THE EXACT
SAME THING.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TOUGH
RHETORIC, CALLING FOR MEXICO
TO DISBAND THIS CARAVAN AS
YOU SEE OF ASYLUM SEEKERS
HEADING FOR THE U.S. BORDER.
THAT'S ALSO WORKING.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, MORE
THAN A THOUSAND PERSON
CARAVAN IS NOW FALLING
APART.
LEADERS OF THE GROUP ARE NOW
SAYING THEY WILL NO LONGER
HEAD FOR AMERICA'S SOUTHERN
BORDER.
OF THIS IS THE START OF GOOD
NEWS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
LOOK AT THIS, A BRAND NEW
RASMUSSEN POLL, HIS APPROVAL
RATING IS NOW 51%, WHICH IS
HIGHER THAN BARACK OBAMA'S
DURING THE EXACT SAME TIME
IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
HE WAS ONLY AT 46%.
AND HE GOT REELECTED.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA PROBABLY
WON'T BE TELLING YOU THAT
TONIGHT.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY
ORCHESTRATING ONSLAUGHT OF
ANY NEGATIVE STORY THEY CAN
POSSIBLY FIND OBSESSING OVER
STORMY DANIELS AND
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
THERE IS ALSO A FAKE NEWS
CNN POLL.
THIS IS PRETTY AMAZING.
WE SHOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
MAKING MAJOR GAINS WITH FOUR
KEY GROUPS.
8 POINTS WITH MEN SINCE
FEBRUARY.
5 POINTS WITH YOUNGER
VOTERS, 9 POINTS WITH MIDDLE
AGED VOTERS AND UP 10 POINTS
WITH COLLEGE GRADUATES.
HERE'S WHAT'S SO INTERESTING
ABOUT THESE POLLS, JUST
IMAGINE IF THE PRESIDENT
WASN'T CONSTANTLY UNDER
ATTACK FROM A MEDIA THAT
WANTS TO DESTROY HIM.
IMAGINE IF ROBERT MUELLER
AND HIS TEAM OF DEMOCRATIC
DONORS WEREN'T CARRYING OUT
THEIR NEVER ENDING
WITCH-HUNT.
DON'T YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S POLL NUMBERS
WOULD BE A LOT HIGHER IF A
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY
WASN'T BEING FED AN ENDLESS
STREAM OF OUTRIGHT LIES,
PROPAGANDA, DISTORTION AND
MISINFORMATION?
NOW, DESPITE ALL OF THAT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS JUST
ROLLING ALONG DOING HIS JOB
EVERY DAY.
THE JOB THAT YOU ELECTED HIM
TO DO.
LOOK AT THIS, MANUFACTURING
THIS IS GOOD NEWS, BY THE
WAY, FOR THE MEDIA TO BE SO
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR ATTACKS
AGAINST TRUMP, THEY ARE KIND
OF CHEERING AGAINST THE
COUNTRY SUCCEEDING.
LOOK AT THIS, THE STRONGEST
IN THREE YEARS.
ADP, MOODY'S ANALYTICS,
SAYING 241,000 JOBS CREATED
IN MARCH.
THAT'S ON TOP OF THE RECORD
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
THAT WE NOW HAVE.
OVER 3 MILLION JOBS CREATED
SINCE DONALD TRUMP ELECTED.
BY THE WAY, THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS EVER
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
HISPANIC AMERICANS.
LOOK AT THIS, HOME EQUITY AT
THIS AT RECORD LEVEL.
$5.4 TRILLION.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO TAKING
A BIG STEP.
THIS IS AMAZING.
NOBODY EVER REPORTS IT.
TO MAKE HEALTHCARE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYBODY AND
GETTING AROUND SOME OF THE
DEVASTATING OBAMACARE
MANDATES.
THERE IS AN OP-ED IN "U.S.A.
TODAY" EXPLAINS HOW THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
SET TO LAY OUT A NEW RULE.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO IMPLEMENT
THIS.
IT WILL LOWER THE COST.
CREATE CHOICES BY EXPANDING
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS.
THESE PLANS ALLOW BUSINESSES
AND TRADE ASSOCIATIONS TO
COME TOGETHER AND BUY HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS IN BULK.
THAT SAVES A TON OF MONEY.
AND BY THE WAY A HUGE
DEVELOPMENT.
YOU GET MORE CARE FOR LESS
MONEY.
OF THE PRESIDENT ALSO IS
TAKING STEPS TO REDUCE THE
BLOAT.
REMEMBER THAT 1.3
TRILLION-DOLLAR OKAY MY BUS
SPENDING BILL THAT NOBODY
LIKED?
WELL, THANK GOD, HE IS -- HE
RELUCTANTLY SIGNED IT, THIS
IS THE BILL THE PRESIDENT
THREATENED TO VETO.
HE WAS FORCED TO KIND OF
SIGN IT WELL CONGRESS LEFT
TOWN.
THEY ARE TOO LAZY.
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS
LOOKING INTO USING WHAT IS
KNOWN AS THE IMPOUNDMENT
CONTROL LACK.
IT'S A LAW FROM 1974.
IT GIVES THE PRESIDENT THE
AUTHORITY TO CANCEL SPENDING
ALREADY APPROVED BY
CONGRESS.
BY THE WAY, THEY ONLY NEED
51 VOTES IN THE SENATE,
MITCH.
NOW, CONGRESS WOULD HAVE 45
DAYS TO APPROVE THE
PRESIDENT'S REQUEST TO CUT
FROM THE MASSIVE SPENDING
BILL.
AGAIN, HE IS KEEPING A
PROMISE.
LET'S HOPE THAT HAPPENS.
THEN, ON TOP OF ALL OF, THIS
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THE SIDE
OF YOUR SCREEN.
YOU WILL NEVER SEE THIS IN
THE MEDIA.
A LIST OF JUST SOME OF THE
PRESIDENT'S MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS DURING HIS
SHORT TIME IN OFFICE.
REMEMBER THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION THEY DID A STUDY
THE PRESIDENT'S FIRST YEAR,
THEY FOUND HE HAS ALREADY
ACCOMPLISHED 64% OF HIS
AGENDA, WHICH BY THE WAY, IS
HIGHER THAN RONALD REAGAN'S
49% AT THE SAME TIME IN HIS
PRESIDENCY.
THESE ARE REAL, TANGIBLE
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT HELP THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN THAT
VOTED IN NOVEMBER OF 2016
THAT THE LIBERAL MEDIA WILL
NEVER TALK ABOUT BECAUSE
THEY NEVER WANT TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT CREDIT FOR
ANYTHING.
AND AS WE HAVE BEEN
EXPLAINING PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS JUST ON FIRE AND IT'S
TIME FOR CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS TO FOLLOW SUIT.
TIME TO GET A BACK POPE.
TIME TO KEEP THEIR PROMISES.
NO MORE WAITING AROUND.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN
2018.
IT'S TIME FOR MEMBERS OF THE
G.O.P., KEEP THEIR WORD.
KEEP THEIR PROMISES.
AND THAT MEANS THEY SHOULD
BUILD THIS SOMEONE WALL.
THEY SHOULD KEEP THE 7 YEAR
PROM NOISE REPEAL AND
REPLACE OBAMACARE.
THINGS THEY SAID AND
PROMISED WHEN THEY WERE
CAMPAIGNING.
HERE'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IF REPUBLICANS DON'T
KEEP THEIR PROMISES,
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO TRY
TO SYSTEMATICALLY UNDO EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, WE WILL PUT
THEM BACK ON THE SCREEN.
NANCY PELOSI HAS ALREADY
THREATENED SHE WILL TRY
REPEAL THE TAX CUTS THAT
BENEFIT 90% OF AMERICANS.
BY THE WAY, YOU KEEP GOING,
NANCY, GOOD JOB.
DON'T STOP.
I WANT YOU TO STAY ON
MESSAGE.
IT'S UP TO CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS TO SHOW SOME
BACKBONE, SOME SPINE AND
ACTUALLY FIGHT FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA THAT YOU
VOTED FOR.
NOW, FORMER HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN JASON
CHAFFETZ.
NOW, HE IS GOING TO JOIN
NEWS A FEW MINUTES.
HE'S OUT WITH A LIST 10
THINGS CONGRESS SHOULD BE
DOING RIGHT NOW.
IN THE ARTICLE CHAFFETZ
SUGGEST CONGRESS SHOULD
EXPLAIN AND CLARIFY THE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST ON
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER'S
TEAM.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS AN
EXPLANATION.
THEY SHOULD FORMALLY DEMAND
THE APPOINTMENT OF A SECOND
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WITH THE
POWER TO PROSECUTE.
HE LISTS CALL FISA COURT
JUDGES BEFORE CONGRESS TO
OFFER PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
THEY WERE ALL LIED TO.
CALL ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS TO TESTIFY ABOUT
OUTSTANDING CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENAS.
HOLD HEARINGS ON SECURING
OUR BORDERS.
FORTIFYING THEM WITH A WALL
AND THEN PASS LEGISLATION
ALLOWING THE PRESIDENT TO
REALLOCATE FUNDS FROM THE
DOD.
AND, OF COURSE, OAKLAND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF SHOULD BE
CALLED TO TESTIFY.
FACEBOOK'S MARK ZUCKERBERG
AND TWITTER'S JACK DOORSY.
THEY SHOULD BE CALLED TO
TESTIFY ABOUT SPEECH
SUPPRESSION PRACTICES.
THIS ESPECIALLY AGAINST
CONSERVATIVES.
ZUCKERBERG WILL TESTIFY
BEFORE LAWMAKERS NEXT WEEK
ABOUT CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA.
NOW CONGRESS BY THE WAY
SHOULD MAKE AN EFFORT TO
REFORM THE BROKEN BUDGET
PROCESS.
THEY SHOULD GIVE STATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON
WHETHER CONGRESS SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO BALANCING THE
FEDERAL BUDGET AND FINALLY
THE SENATE SHOULD REFUSE TO
RECESS UNTIL EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
APPOINTEES HAVE BEEN VOTED
ON.
MITCH, TIME TO WORK.
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZLIKE
HERE IN A MINUTE.
FIRST, WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
HOUSE INTEL CHAIRMAN DEVIN
NUNES HAS SENT A LETTER TO
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
NUNES IS BLASTING THE
REPEATED STONEWALLING BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHICH
IS BEING LED BY ROSENSTEIN
AND REFUSING CONTINUALLY TO
HAND OVER DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED BY
CONGRESS.
REMEMBER, ROSENSTEIN IS THE
GUY THAT RAN IN TO PAUL
RYAN'S OFFICE BACK IN
JANUARY AT THE LAST HOUR
BEGGING SPEAKER RYAN TO
BLOCK CONGRESSMAN NUNES'
REQUEST FOR DOCUMENTS ABOUT
ALL THE FISA ABUSES IN THE
DOSSIER.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE LEARNED
THAT HAD PAUL RYAN
CAPITULATED.
WITHOUT THOSE DOCUMENTS
THERE NEVER WOULD HAVE BEEN
A NUNES MEMO AND WOULDN'T
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT ANY OF THE
MASSIVE SCANDALS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT EVERY NIGHT
UNFOLDING LIKE THE FISA
ABUSE, LYING TO JUDGES TO
GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON A
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE.
IN THAT CASE CARTER PAGE.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, WHY DOES HE
WANT TO KEEP ALL OF THIS A
SECRET?
WHY DOES HE WANT TO PROTECT
ALL HIS CORRUPT FRIENDS?
NOW AFTER MONTHS OF
OBSTRUCTING, CHAIRMAN NUNES
IS DEMANDING ANSWERS.
BY THE WAY NUNES HAS BEEN
ASKING FOR DOCUMENTS.
SOME GO BACK TO AUGUST OF
2017.
ROD, HAPPENED THE
ROD HHAPPENED THE
ROD HANPPENED THE
ROD HANDPENED THE
ROD HAND TNED THE
ROD HAND THED THE
ROD HAND THE DTHE
ROD HAND THE DOCE
ROD HAND THE DOCUMENTS OVER
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S HOW RIDICULOUS THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS IS AND NUNES
IS NOW REQUESTING THE DOJ DO
THEIR JOB AND, OF COURSE,
CONGRESS HAS THEIR JOBS, WE
HAVE CHECKS AND BALANCES, WE
HAVE COEQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
THE DOJ TURN OVER UNREDACTED
VERSION OF UNREDACTED MEMO
OF THE OPENING OF THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
NUNES SET A DEADLINE
GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
ROSENSTEIN, IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE A LONG TIME
BEFORE THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE GETS TO SEE THIS.
THE LEVEL OF OBSTRUCTION AND
PROTECTION, THE INCESTUOUS
NATURE OF THE RELATIONSHIPS,
THIS IS BEYOND DISGRACEFUL.
ROSENSTEIN HAS DONE
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE THAT HE
CAN DO TO PREVENT CONGRESS
FROM DOING THEIR JOB WHICH
IS OVERSIGHT.
THEY HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL NOT
ONLY RIGHT BUT DUTY TO DO
SO.
IT'S TIME FOR ROD ROSENSTEIN
TO STOP HIDING THE TRUTH
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HIS BOSS IS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS.
AND JEFF SESSIONS RIGHTLY
SAID LAST WEEK THAT HE IS
ANGRY AT THE SLOW PACE THAT
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE BEING
TURNED OVER.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WELL, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
NEEDS TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
ANGRY, HE NEEDS TO TAKE
ACTION AND FORCE THE DEPUTY
A.G. ROSENSTEIN TO DO HIS
JOB.
IF ROSENSTEIN DOESN'T WANT
TO, THEN HE NEEDS TO GO.
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK CONGRESS NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO GET ANSWERS ON
BEHALF OF YOU.
WE NOW SEE CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
YOU HAVE A CORRUPT MEDIA,
THEY ARE IN MAJOR DENIAL.
THEY ARE BESIDES THEMSELVES
OVER REPORTS THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID NOT CURRENTLY --
LET ME REPEAT, NOT A TARGET
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER WANTS CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION.
NOW, DESPITE THIS NEW
DEVELOPMENT, THE MEDIA IS
DESPERATE.
THEY ARE HOLDING OUT HOPE.
THEY ARE ON THEIR KNEES.
THEY ARE PRAYING TO GOD THAT
SOMEHOW, SOME WAY, ROBERT
MUELLER WILL STILL FIND A
WAY TO MAKE DONALD TRUMP THE
TARGET AND GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT.
THINK THROUGH THIS.
IF THAT EVER HAPPENED, IS
THAT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY?
IS THAT GOOD FOR THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE COUNTRY?
DOES THAT CREATE JOBS?
DOES THAT GET PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY AND CREATE FOOD
STAMPS?
NO.
DOES IT KEEP US SAFER?
>> DO THEY SEEM TO CARE?
NO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SUBJECT MEANS SOMEONE OF
INTEREST TO THE GRAND JURY.
ALSO SOMEONE ON THE ROAD
BEING CHARGED WITH A CRIME.
IT'S A BIG DEAL TO BE UNDER
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION BY
THE FBI, PARTICULARLY IF YOU
ARE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> CERTAINLY BEING THE
SUBJECT THEY SHOULDN'T CRACK
OPEN THE 14578 PAIN BEING
THE TARGET OF AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> TARGET IS SOMEBODY THEY
ARE GOING TO INDICT.
PRESIDENT BY POLICY IS NOT
BE INDICTED.
IT'S A LITTLE VEGAS WHAT
THEY ARE MEANING, MAY BE TO
MAKE MR. TRUMP RELAX.
>> IF SOMEONE WALKED INTO MY
OFFICE AND SAID I WAS THE
SUBJECT OF A MULTIYEAR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION LED
BY FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
ROBERT MUELLER, I WOULD WET
MY PANTS.
>> NONTARGET LETTER ISN'T
WORTH THE PAPER THAT IT'S
PRINTED ON.